[Musique]
et
il était 6h30 car je suis arrivé le
matin ici et déjà ici sur la scène 90 il
y avait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
déchet il ya beaucoup de vida logicil
afghane avait tellement que je devrais
les contourner avec mon vélo ce monsieur
hamel mario il vient il s'approche de
moi mais tu viens d ici nos vielles si
tu vas te ranger à face à mater et c'est
là un petit peu plus loin que j'ai
appelé le 9 heures
[Musique]
7 juin 2011 centre ville de montréal
quatre policiers larmes au point en
cercle mario hamel et lui ordonne de
lâcher son couteau hamel refusent ils se
déplacent rapidement vers la rue saint
denis
les policiers tentent de désarmer en
utilisant un gel de poivre de cayenne
grâce au même moment j'entends trop
coups de feu à quelle distance de en
terme de temps les coups de feu n'ont
même pas une seconde
mario hamel reçoit une balle au thorax
de l'autre côté de la rue patrick
limoges un simple passant est atteint
mortellement d'une balle perdue
bavures policières ou légitime défense
une équipe de la sûreté du québec
enquête sur la fusillade
[Musique]
monde
de notre côté on entreprend de fouiller
le passé de mario hamel aurait on pu
l'empêcher de devenir un danger public
[Musique]
quelques heures après le drame j'arrive
rue sainte catherine je cherche
quelqu'un qui connaisse c'est mario
hamel
ah ouais
t'as pour mauvais jour démenti dès ma
deuxième itinéraire pas vrai les restes
et
mario hamel avait une chambre rue saint
denis mais il passait ses journées ici
rue de bullion
c'était le vendeur de potes du point un
gars tranquille jusqu'à tout récemment
il vient s'intégrer après tout le monde
à l'été 2012 de 12 avril on sait qu'un
mari avait un couteau
ça faisait 12 tours en chemin qui avait
un couteau vaches kg celui des taxis
perrotin
pour en savoir davantage je me rends aux
funérailles de mario hamel
je rencontre barbara sa mère
et isabelle son ex conjointe mario hamel
avec quatre enfants dans la salle je
croise plusieurs membres du personnel de
l'accueil bonneau un refuge pour les
hommes de la rue je fais aussi la
connaissance de daniel un ami d'enfance
avec tous ces gens là pendant des
semaines je vais parcourir la ville afin
de comprendre pourquoi mario hamel s'est
retrouvée sous les balles des policiers
en 1971 la mère de mario barbara à 16
lorsqu'elle accouche elle est incapable
de s'occuper du bébé seul mais refuse de
l'abandonner elle le confie à une
famille où ils veulent visiter
régulièrement pendant son enfance et son
adolescence
mario séjournent dans deux familles et
deux centres d'accueil mario est un
enfant blessé qui toute sa vie va en
vouloir à sa mère moi j'ai voulu quand
j'ai appelé mathieu plus vieille
j'aurais voulu réparer mais taro pin en
prendre un pour l'aider mais de la
confiance tapis lors je pense qu'il y
avait beaucoup beaucoup de difficultés à
l'école puis avait beaucoup de
difficultés personnelles puis ça fais en
sorte que ça bougeait beaucoup autour de
lui les mêmes jeunes à l'école l'iddac
cpi accepta pour sa vie telle qu'elle
était à 16 ans mario n'a pas encore
complété son secondaire 2 il quitte
l'école pour travailler à 19 ans il
rencontre celle qui deviendra sa
conjointe isabelle des jo à style
j'étais déjà embarqué un petit peu dans
le rôle de la sauveuse moi j'avais un
beau projet de vie à ce moment là puis
je le voyais déjà comme étant
potentiellement le père de mozart
le petit mathieu arrive après deux ans
de vie commune
ça a été le coup de foudre avec ses
enfants un lot il y avait vraiment une
belle relation avec son fils c'était
merveilleux de le voir aller dormir avec
lui la lui le stock comme une bouée de
sauvetage mais quelque chose qui
quittent réconcilie avec la vie ou qui
te fait dire
même si j'ai pas eu confiance en rien
dans vie même si aurier qui m'a jamais
donné confiance maintenant j'ai mathieu
puis ça c'est quelque chose de deux
gigantesques pour
en l'espace de sept ans la famille a
quatre enfants ils vivent de l'aide
sociale et des petits boulots de mario
mario est un père très présent et m il y
avait un coeur de 10 avec ses enfants et
des fois c'était presque une relation
amicale une relation de l'essai de
laisser à l'ide laisser vivre c'était
toute sa vie ses enfants steve la main
le centre de sa vie parlait de ses
enfants sans
appui je pense qu'il les aimait
profondément à sa façon à lui avec ses
capacités avec lui
mais au fil des ans mario fument de plus
en plus de drogues et son état mental se
détériore commence à voir des
comportements
différent dans sa façon de parler et
d'agir qu'à ce moment là
tout le temps des discours religieux qui
reviennent lui avait commencé à étudier
la bible les textes de l'abbé bien
commencé à écrire
créer ses explications de la vie des
écritures bibliques le je me disais oh
il ya quelque chose qui qui au delà de 2
ma compréhension loger
au lieu de dormir la nuit mario
entreprend de réécrire la bible oui
voyait comme un nouveau mais c'est comme
si tu aimerais vraiment le fils de dieu
une journée je reviens à la maison puis
est en train de faire une étude biblique
à la table la cuisine avec des témoins
de jéhovah plus étudier avec eux plus
est sombre et un petit peu dans son
délire religieux peut s'amener à sa
première cause
[Applaudissements]
des épisodes mystique délirant au
psychotique mario van vivre plusieurs et
sa consommation de drogue va augmenter
jusqu'à une dizaine de joints par jour
comme très peu conscience de la réalité
y aura rien dollars est moindre titre
est à le faire self éclaté à plusieurs
reprises isabelle est victime de
violences elle porte plainte et mario
est accusé de voies de fait et de
menaces de mort nous avons obtenu des
enregistrements d'un procès qui a eu
lieu en 2003 isabelle raconte que mario
a menacé de l'étrangler devant son fils
de 8 ans
il est cocasse mais je voyais jamais
porté fait contre il ya toujours eu des
faux culs et
dans le box des accusés
mario témoigne à son tour
on entend son délire et sa violence
envers isabelle mais bon je m'en fous de
la vérité je
vous demande votre appart et la magie
commence vraiment aidé quand il faut
jeter par les cheveux le prix fort j'ai
quand même que ce bon vieux cuir et
ainsi qu'avec
mon dieu mais les 32 trophées elle
demande un peu spéciales notamment
j'adore
[Musique]
mario est incarcéré à de multiples
reprises et fait au moins quatre séjours
en hôpital psychiatrique
entre autres à l'institut philippe pinel
à son arrivée dans cet établissement
mario confié à un psychiatre qu'il veut
sauver le monde unifié les pays devenir
premier ministre de la planète devenir
champion mondial de boxe pour mieux
évangéliser
à l'hôpital douglas il dit que s'il
avait une mitraillette ils
l'utiliseraient et qu'il souhaite pour
l'euthanasie il raconte qu isabelle fait
exprès pour qu'il la frappe parce
qu'elle veut le faire interner mise
croyait pas malade c'est moi qui étais
folle moi je voulais le faire interner
juste pour me débarrasser de lui la star
ce point là donc il m'en a voulu
nommément à toutes les fois qu'ils
étalent à l'hôpital pour lui c'était de
ma faute à moi juste un mois qui aurait
eu besoin de soins ce témoin qui devait
être soigné
mario a reçu une panoplie de diagnostic
à maisonneuve heureusement psychose
l'aigu d'origine toxiques relié à une
forte consommation de marijuana à
l'institut pinel troubles délirants
grandiose a dog le trouble de la
personnalité narcissique et antisociales
les diagnostics diffèrent et les
propositions de traitement sur semble
être suivi par un psychiatre prendre des
médicaments antipsychotiques à chaque
fois marion refuse catégoriquement de se
faire soigner pointe the mais je sais
que ce qu'ils vont nous et je sais qu
est ce qui montre qu'ils vont donner des
médicaments
ils ne se ressemblent pas on ne pouvait
pas imposer des soins
ça fonctionne pas les médecins nous
disent toujours on peut pas forcer le
monde d'avoir delahaye qui entraîne pas
d'arpilles c'était le problème à
marie-odile ne voulait pas de l'arrêter
la loi québécoise est clair impossible
de forcer quelqu'un à se faire soigner
s'il ne représente pas un danger grave
et imminent
[Musique]
en 2003 au terme du procès pour voies de
fait contre isabelle mario est déclaré
non responsable criminellement pour
cause de troubles mentaux
même là on ne réussit pas à le forcer à
se faire soigner après trois mois de
prison et d'hospitalisation sans
consommation de drogue les symptômes
psychotiques ont disparu
[Musique]
mario est renvoyé à la maison
pour isabelle c'est un retour à la case
départ moi j'ai accepté de leur prendre
part qu'à quelque part je me disais ce
pour le meilleur pour le pays je me
disais il va se ramassent à la rue donc
je le voyais qui était pas apte à se
refaire une vie qui n'était pas assez
solide donc à ce moment là j'ai commencé
moi je le traînait comme un boulet le
désosser un gros fardeau parce que
j'étais responsable de lui comme
stendhal enfin le en 2009 la famille est
au bord de l'éclatement vivre tellement
mal que c'est les enfants qui commencent
à subir tellement de conséquences
le plus jeune des garçons fini par
dénoncer la violence dont il est victime
au travailleur social de l'école pensent
qu'elle est passé devant la télé pendant
ta pas jouer au jeu ça y avait fait
perdre sa gaine ya comme une vraiment
pousser le petit dans la meuse qui le
montait dans le prix le prix à lagord
[Musique]
cette fois-ci mario est accusé de voies
de fait sur les enfants il est arrêté
puis libéré en attente de son procès
mais on lui impose une condition ne plus
s'approcher de ses enfants
je sais pas c'est dans la relation avec
isabelle que la coupure avec ses enfants
qui a été comme
une catastrophe c'est comme ça on est à
la salle car ces enfants c'est tout ce
qu'ils avaient
pendant cinq mois à l'hiver 2009 mario
vie dans la rue et dort dans des refuges
il est complètement perdue moi je pense
que l'oeil est un dépression parce
qu'ils me parlait qui avait qui avaient
plus faim il y avait plus le goût de
manger qui pleurait toutes les nuits qui
arrêtait pas de penser à ses enfants
comme une obsession comme quelque chose
qui je peux pas te l'arraché comme une
chanson pitot qui tombe dit on
mario finit par emménager dans cette
maison de chambres de l'accueil bonneau
le directeur de l'accueil aubin boudreau
se souvient de mario avec émotion
mario avait deux objectifs dans l'oeuf
en dessous et il voulait augmenter ses
revenus pour
gâter ses enfants c'est ce qui nous
oblige de prendre soin de mes enfants je
vais avoir la chance
des hommes à la ronde au cinéma
donc on l'a inscrit sur un programme
d'employabilité et puis voulait
développer des habiletés pour retourner
éventuellement sur le marché du travail
pendant près d'un an mario travaille au
centre de jour de l'accueil bonneau il
est préposé aux douches la route est
toujours assidu toujours ponctuel
toujours présent et puis ben yahia bien
il ya bien rempli son mandat pour
augmenter ses revenus mario commence à
vendre du pote sur la rue de bullion
malgré cela il continue de remonter la
pente
consommer pratiquement plus on était
bien fière d'y avoir à bien s'organiser
être fonctionnels ils réussissent à
payer ses comptes
les choses se gâtent au printemps 2011
mario est arrêté sa drogue et saisi il
se fait battre par son fournisseur
pendant la même période
il apprend qu isabelle va emménager avec
son nouveau conjoint elle a des trucs à
la part de permettre à ce qu'on était
pour disparaître jamais nous voir so
c'est sa plus grande part et c'est ça
qui est en train de se passer oui moi
déménageant c'est comme ce test est
clair que que je voulais pas qu'elle nos
coordonnées dit ou d'aucune façon à
partir de là mario dérape ses
connaissances de la rue affirme qu'ils
commencent à consommer du crack et qu'il
s'arme de couteau pour se protéger
comme à chaque apathie
nourrir les
enfants
qu'à patrick à passer des caps à terre
du côté de l'accueil bonneau on remarque
que mario décline qu'on attendait d'eux
l'encadré davantage l'amener à utiliser
d'autres services existent mais discours
mais enfin
mario ont refusé c'était de l'eau et
puis n'ayant pas n'étant pas considéré
comme dangereux pour lui même ni pour
autrui dans un avenir proche
dangereux mario l'est devenu deux
semaines avant sa mort à deux reprises
il débarque chez sa mère en état de
crise et la police doit intervenir le
chant la police était cependant vers la
wii et on a envoyé à killeen parce qu'il
avait pris les deux bacs à fleurs en
avant de la clôture puis il a
entièrement brisées avec ses mains tout
en bois qui est gâchée au plein milieu
de la rue après ça il y avait des gars
aussi comme la mairie à poillé la bct a
tout arraché devant les policiers mario
menace sa mère de la nuit il commence à
me parler d'un truc tout moche qui avait
choqué et puis
on dirait que c'est un job in the world
et obligé de partir en tournée dans
maison jean n'a pas trop paru ce jour là
les policiers ont raté une belle
occasion
parce que mario était menaçant et
délirant il aurait pu l'emmener à
l'hôpital de force au lieu de cela ils
ont refilé le fardeau à barbara en lui
suggérant de faire une demande
d'évaluation psychiatrique
mais barbara n'y croyait pulsé j'aurais
fait ça mario il a été plus agressif de
la prochaine fois ce sera ta conscience
ça n'a rien donné on ne saura jamais
exactement ce qui a provoqué l'ultime
délire de mario ce qui est clair c'est
que le 7 juin au matin il a explosive
à l'aube mario s'est rendu rue de
bullion pour emprunter ce véhicule afin
d'aller voir ses enfants le propriétaire
du véhicule nous a raconté ce qui s'est
passé
mario et déchaînés ils vandalisent le
véhicule et passe le reste de sa colère
sur les ordures de la rue sainte
catherine mais qu'est ce qui a bien pu
déclencher une telle fureur
isabelle a peut-être une explication
moi j'ai quitté la main englobe et à
bromont le 30 mai
par contre à priori une bonne semaine
avant que
la débrancher le 6 juin la veille de sa
mort et de femmes mario téléphoner chez
isabelle tous les jours quand la ligne
téléphonique a été débranchée il a
probablement perdu pied un témoin aurait
dit aux enquêteurs de la sûreté du
québec que ce matin là il avait
l'intention de s'en prendre à sa famille
isabelle n'arrive pas à y croire je peux
poser croire
que la personne qui était mario avec le
grand quart qui avait parait voulu poser
un geste extrême de violences envers moi
et ses enfants c'est ça démonte une
détresse épouvantable
entre 1997 et 2011 mario hamel a été
traduit d'une douzaine de fois devant
les tribunaux
il a été hospitalisé en psychiatrie à au
moins quatre reprises
au nom de la liberté tout le monde a
respecté son refus de se faire soigner
le 7 juin dernier quand mario hamel
s'est retrouvé dans la mire des
policiers armés d'un couteau il était
trop tard trop tard aussi pour patrick
limoges qui passait par là au mauvais
moment
[Musique]